what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some huge news about
the upcoming Fantastic Four movie that
is going to be making its way to the MCU
in a couple of years hopefully nothing
gets delayed and we do indeed get it in
2025. now today we have some insight on
why the Fantastic Four movie got delayed
in the first place and some news from
some insiders telling us a little bit
about the plot of the movie and I must
say it's a really cool plot point that I
enjoy and this goes along with Kevin
feige the president of Marvel Studios
stating that this isn't going to be a
traditional Fantastic Four origin story
we know how Marvel Studios and Kevin
feige like to do this they sometimes
don't like to play the traditional
origin story game with new characters
they are introducing to the MCU
Spider-Man homecoming was the perfect
example we didn't see the spider bite we
didn't see Peter Parker get his powers
he simply already had his powers when we
met him this will be the same for the
Fantastic Four we also have some casting
updates today with which I know
everybody is really excited about
figuring out who is going to play Sue
storm Reed Richards Ben Grimm and Johnny
Storm and if you love The Fantastic Four
and want to stay up to date on them and
the MCU in general be sure to subscribe
to the channel we talk about Marvel
almost every single day and if you
subscribe and comment it also enters you
in our giveaway we are giving away an
Xbox series X A PS5 some Marvel Legends
stuff and some DC memorabilia as well
each month so who will be our Marvel's
first family well according to some
insiders they have been cast at least
Sue storm and Reed Richards The
Invisible Woman and Mr Fantastic now the
Fantastic Four movie was delayed because
Marvel is making kind of a shift in
their entire schedule most of you
probably know that Kevin feige and
Disney CEO Bob Iger have stated that
they are going to cut back on their
output and focus on quality over
quantity and that's exactly what is
happening with the Fantastic Four and
this is incredible news in fact if you
haven't heard Marvel Studios has
recently gotten a new writer for the
Fantastic Four movie so needless to say
no the script is not complete yet but
not only is the Fantastic Four MCU movie
Kevin feige's baby his passion project
but on top of that Marvel Studios is
putting a lot more care into their
future projects this is why the
Fantastic Four got delayed in the first
place and why it might actually be
delayed again but the fact that they got
a new writer for the film is great news
and it seemingly kind of changes how the
film is actually going to be tonally it
kind of looks like Marvel Studios has
learned from some audiences that we
don't want rapid fire jokes every single
minute and that we do want them to take
their time and establish deep emotional
connections with us and the characters
they are showing us and that connection
between the characters that we are
seeing on screen as well now originally
the Fantastic Four MCU film was going to
be written by Jeff Kaplan and Ian
Springer writers with comedic
backgrounds but according to a report
from The Hollywood Reporter Josh fry
Weidman is now going to be writing the
Fantastic Four film and his background
is very different than a comedic
background for example Josh freudman
wrote Avatar 2 The Way of the water he
also developed snow piercer on TNT so
this is a big shift it's almost like
Marvel Studios got the actual feedback
from the fans they were actually
listening and realized that after Thor
love and thunder after Ant-Man and the
WASP want to Mania that the fans
actually do desire kind of deeper movies
yes of course we all love the humor I
especially do but I also do love the
more serious tone as well and I think
this works really great for the
Fantastic Four yes the Fantastic Four of
course can be funny especially the thing
in Johnny Storm but this is going to be
a very huge movie and it does need to be
done correctly and it does need to be
serious perhaps that's why it has taken
so long to find the cast for the film
however according to John campia they
have already been cast and they have
been cast for a while speaking
specifically about Reed Richards and Sue
storm this is what he said on his show
at the end of last month Richards and
Sue storm have both been cast and have
been cast for a while I'm not going to
say much more beyond that I will just
say that if the two are already cast and
and have been cast for a bit I think for
a long time we've believed this isn't
going to be an origin story per se I
think we're going to meet the Fantastic
Four a little further along the line
reports that they're already going to be
parents that makes sense with where my
thinking's at so we'll see So based off
of what John campy has heard and keep in
mind he was the one who released the
pictures of Spider-Man no way home he
did it on accident but still he's got
sources he says Reed Richards and Sue
storm have been cast which is very
interesting because we haven't heard
anything else about who could possibly
be playing these two characters sure we
have had a lot of casting reports happen
recently over the past year or so but
nobody coming out stating that actors
have officially been cast and we're
talking about specific actors now we'll
talk about actors in just a bit however
campia goes on to say that he has heard
reports that this is not going to be an
original origin story like we talked
about and this is what Kevin feige had
to say about that he said a lot of
people know this origin story a lot of
people know the basics how do we take
that and bring something that they've
never seen before we've set a very high
bar for ourselves with bringing that to
the screen so that's what he said in an
interview with The Hollywood Reporter in
regards to not doing a traditional
origin story with the Fantastic Four but
John campus says that he's heard reports
that they're going to be so along the
lines in their development as the
Fantastic Four that Sue storm and Reed
Richards are already going to be parents
and this is really really jumping
forward at least so we think now in the
comics of course Reed Richards and Sue
storm go on to get married and this was
considered one of the biggest comic book
story events of all time it's also very
interesting because the relationship
between Sue and Reed started before they
had their powers Reed and Sue were
dating when they went on that test
flight into space and gain their powers
eventually they would go on to get
married and like I said it was a huge
event if we go straight into them being
parents we are essentially skipping all
of that now it doesn't mean that we
can't have flashbacks or maybe even do a
Disney plus special after the movie gets
released showing us how they met how
they gain their powers Etc but I must
say it is an interesting choice to have
them already be parents now this is just
a report for now it's not necessarily
confirmed because this report has been
going around for a while and it's clear
that Marvel Studios didn't really like
the way the script was going because
they got a new writer so this could very
well not be the case anymore and don't
get me wrong I'm not against this but
going back to what we said about us
having emotional connections and
interests and investments in these
characters we kind of need to see how
they start off how they first start
dating when they get married
Etc and you can still do that and still
have this not be a traditional origin
story now these few reports about Reed
and Sue being parents already in the
Fantastic Four movie are so well known
that we are still hearing from some
insiders about how exactly this will
work even two days ago Alex P from the
cosmic circus replied to a tweet stating
this if anything them hiring Friedman is
to help the family dynamic between the
four feel more real and grounded
especially since there's a chance
Franklin and Valeria May debut too now
Franklin and Valeria are the kids of Sue
storm and Reed Richards but Alex P
replied stating this might want to place
a big pause on Franklin and Valeria
haven't heard there in the Fantastic
Four specifically they might show up
down the road but not in this movie so
this is pretty interesting if they are
indeed going to be parents in this film
their kids are going to be probably very
very little like just born maybe because
make no mistake their kids are super
important in fact their son Franklin
Richards is one of the most if not the
most powerful mutant to ever exist in
Marvel history so their children are 100
going to be important however they most
likely really aren't going to be the
focus of the Fantastic Four movie
obviously they probably will just simply
address the fact that they have kids and
then go on a mission if they are already
established as the Fantastic Four then
we can probably see them taking on
villains and that would definitely
explain why the kids weren't there
you're obviously not taking newborns or
very young children to fight bad guys in
fact in the comics Agatha Harkness
becomes the nanny for their kids so
there are a lot of really big
connections that the MCU could make with
the Fantastic Four and it's great news
if they have already been cast I hope we
get an announcement soon now the front
runner for Sue storm lately has been
Jody Comer and she was recently on the
happy sad confused podcast and she was
asked if she had heard these rumors and
if she had a response to them and this
is what she said in response to if she's
heard the rumors she said I am now after
the last year no guys I don't know
anything about it I feel like when I say
this people are like oh okay kind of
like okay sure then she continues to say
it's like you can't win either way even
though she did kind of give us a typical
response of somebody who could be in the
movie but can't say anything she
continues to say I think Never Say Never
but right now no but I think Never Say
Never right I think as I said before
usually when you finish one project you
then want to try something very
different so I don't know maybe now
obviously we know that even if she were
cast as Sue storm she could not say
anything Kevin feige has multiple
snipers pointed at so many people
anytime they do an interview or simply
just say anything these actors clearly
cannot say if they are cast in a movie
Paul Rudd said he wasn't Ant-Man and Bam
he was Ant-Man Andrew Garfield stated so
many times that he wasn't the werewolf
that he wasn't in Spider-Man no way home
and alas he was so Jody Comer still
could very well be our Sue storm now as
far as dude the rest could be we really
don't know if anybody has been pinned
down yet but of course if we hear
anything we'll be sure to do an update
video so be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
Fantastic Four MCU and DC news and of
course it also enters you in our
giveaway please don't forget to like the
video and of course you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching woof woof